hasta qué punto repsol es responsable
por el derrame de petróleo de petróleo
al haberse producido por el oleaje
causado por un fenómeno natural
bueno muchas gracias por la oportunidad
aquí tenemos que analizar dos momentos
el primer momento es cómo se produjo las
circunstancias en las que se produjo
este derrame y ahí se está haciendo la
investigación la empresa dice que desde
el día anterior están haciendo la
descarga y que consultaron si existía
alguna alerta a raíz de la situación de
tonga no tuvieron información al
respecto de una alerta de su también por
lo tanto continuaron con el proceso y
tuvieron la diligencia debida eso es lo
que hay que investigar porque si de
repente si pudieron haber tomado la
decisión de parar la descarga esto no se
hubiera producido entonces pues es un
primer elemento para la investigación el
segundo elemento es lo que sea por
negligencia o sea realmente por un hecho
fortuito se produjo este derrame
entonces la empresa tiene que activar
inmediatamente lo que se llaman los
protocolos de contingencia y eso implica
que acciones tiene que tomar
para remediar esta situación y lo
primero es comunicar efectivamente y ahí
es donde creemos que no necesariamente
la comunicación ha sido lo más rápida
posible ni lo más transparente posible
un segundo elemento es tomar acción para
limitar el impacto ahí la empresa ha
manifestado que ha puesto un cerco
digamos para controlar que esto no se
siga expandiendo lo tercero son las
operaciones para el recojo del crudo y
sacarlo del agua y evitar que siga
también siga afectando a la flora ya la
fauna
lo siguiente es
identificar toda la fauna silvestre que
se pueda tratar de rescatar tratar con
los veterinarios de hacer las
operaciones de limpieza de las aves de
los lobos recordemos que efectivamente
son dos áreas naturales protegidas donde
tenemos fauna silvestre importante la
gran biodiversidad
y finalmente es toda la parte de la
operación de limpieza en el terreno de
la costa de la playa y ahí es donde le
pedimos no es cierto el existimos en
realidad como ciudadanos a la empresa
que ponga la mayor diligencia el mayor
sentido de urgencia
sobre esta situación